assessing the damage from above after
mount simeru spewed piles of ash 12 000
meters into the sky
down below entire homes have been
submerged villages blanketed with
falling ash the creeping lava is
destroying everything in its path
sumeru is one of indonesia's nearly 130
active volcanoes
and is the highest peak on the nation's
most densely populated island of java
the sudden eruption was triggered by
days of heavy rain
everyone was scared and running in panic
because this eruption was much bigger
than the eruption that occurred last
year
smoldering debris thick smoke and power
outages have hampered search and rescue
operations
evacuation efforts have been suspended
for now with the cloud surrounding the
affected area remaining too hot to
handle
people who managed to escape have been
staying at this evacuation center
the people behind me are evacuated local
villages at the moment they need
assistance like daily necessities food
and drinks
we also don't know how long they need to
stay here for
those who want to return home have been
told they can't
and to stay far away from the crater's
mouth
the volcano had seen an increase in
activity in recent days but its alert
status was not raised
now many here want to know why they
weren't warned
why
they are caught by surprise what went
wrong
is somebody sleeping on the job or
our way of communicating the danger is
not sufficient
an answer many will be seeking as they
pick up the pieces of what is left
behind
jillian wolf
al jazeera